I may remember the Arab Spring this is
you know where all these rights were
gonna come in and everyone was gonna be
treated equally and there was gonna be
democracy in the Middle East basically
started in Egypt then they got the
Muslim Brotherhood then they overthrew
the Muslim Brotherhood but we don't call
that a coup because we kind of like the
guys that were sort of in in the first
place anyway well a new study has come
out and Egypt which led this thing which
once was the heart of the entire Middle
East that yes Egypt is the worst country
in the Middle East for women let's take
a look
so yeah the worst five the worst five
Arab countries for women Egypt Iraq
which probably has a little something to
do with us Saudi Arabia which we did a
story on two weeks ago that women still
cannot drive their they'll be able to
vote in a couple years but I guess they
won't be able to drive to the polling
stations Syria no surprise there and and
Yemen so let's just start with this yeah
yeah I mean the word men is in there
there should be a funny BuzzFeed article
somewhere in here where it's like top
ten outrageous things you wouldn't see
and it's just all these photo the
picture that was just in the back we
just want me the bad BuzzFeed parity
article because these countries are
going to have terrible policies against
women you know that these countries are
all in such flux and their governments
are crumbling constantly so it's almost
like now a parody but like what do you
expect right and you don't expect more
so the last couple weeks here on the
show we've been doing these kind of
things like a couple weeks ago it came
out that Kuwait is using a system of
gaydar I kid you not to keep gay people
out of Kuwait just one gay guy at the
door like okay so we have gate so gays
obviously not treated well in the Middle
East that's a general rule right so then
if we also have Saudi Arabia is one of
our biggest allies although we're having
some issues with them and women are not
treated equally there now Egypt which
I'm not sure where our alliance is right
at this moment but we have all these
countries that don't even have the sort
of basic human rights not not everyone
has to be treat a great not everyone's
treated great here but should we have
just basic humor your women have to be
just relatively equal is that the Town
Square you shouldn't expect to be
penetrated which it actually says in its
article that nine
80% of the women who welcome to Maine
town square have at some point had
clothing ripped off them or have been
penetrated and then I want to say some
of them were even raped
they're not even concluding they're in
the uprising and if you ask where 99% of
women have said they experienced sexual
harassment not just like whistling from
construction workers like harassed man
but half the people I know half the
people watching this will say the US has
no right to tell anyone what to do and
we don't treat our people that great and
blah blah and I think that's legit and
I'm clearly the way our foreign policy
is we're getting out of all these places
at Main Street USA without the
expectation of being sexually assaulted
right I mean women are still seen as
second-class citizens in this country so
I mean it's it's a it's a it's an uphill
battle for women all the time but I mean
these are cultures that are ancient
cultures that have not have never moved
through the Age of Enlightenment
I mean they're there's no sense of that
part of the evolution the human rights
of man is not a conversation they've had
in their culture yet so this is you know
ancient cultures and this is how they
you know women are absolutely
second-class citizens just to start with
and so but you know we've been doing
this for hundreds of years you know our
policy is well you know we'll you're
you're an important resource for us
whether militarily or oil or whatever it
is so we'll look the other way and then
do you help them okay so that's
interesting and you said I never thought
of it that way that they're not at the
stage of enlightenment like maybe
they're basically on survival and food
and shelter if you look at like Maslow's
pyramid and you look at people's needs
moving up it that's a good point because
it seems like they're still at food
water shelter stability or they're more
like tried their tribal cultures and my
Mideast is a tribal culture and tribal
cultures are not even it's not about a
democracy you know and tribal cultures
women for the most part are you know
treated as as share now that we're a
global village we have access to this
information no people are suffering is
it up to us now to go there and help
them with these basic needs of a that's
the part that's the part that I think is
particularly interesting that never ever
works what works is the people into here
square who originally did this uprising
or people who were educated in the West
who are younger generations who are
attached to the global village through
through the internet and and do have a
different point of view and they were
trying to bring some new energy into
their country unfortunately they didn't
have the political stability or
foundation
and when you you know when you take a
dictator away from these tribal cultures
look at Iraq you take a dictator away
the tribes go crazy and and they go back
five hundred years basically is what
happens and so when you take the kind of
the oppressive forces off of a culture
like that chaos ensues and when chaos
ensues women are victimized
yeah and Egypt is the perfect example of
that because for 30 years they had a
dictator who gave women basically no
rights then they tried democracy and it
got worse for a year and then they
revolted against the democracy and now
they have the same military in that
wisdom of era right yeah but it's war it
is worse now because even you know
Bassam Yosef who's the Jon Stewart of
Egypt he's now been taken off the air he
at least was on air we're talking about
okay I understand it these are tribal
cultures and that they're going to you
know when they're in chaos and when they
don't know what to do we're gonna work
back there and that they have to kind
their own infrastructure and we can't
help them I disagree because our
government is still aiding these other
governments that are now taking
journalists and people yeah basically in
taking them away from the people so if
they can't have ever have an uprising if
they can't have women speaking out to
protect themselves because their
government is being empowered and funded
by people at the u.s. the UK anyone else
is giving them money then we are
indirectly in some way still influencing
them so that helped save them or not
fundamental and not save them just
completely leave it alone but you can't
do both but this doesn't this go to the
fundamental difference between we want
people to have rights so let's say as
the United States we'd like women to
have equal rights but we also want Saudi
Arabia's oil so we're constantly
negotiating how did we do with that or
even in Egypt right now we'd like them
to have more rights but can we say to
these guys who just came into power
again after or not ku can we say well
guys you know you're really otherwise
because we're already taking some of the
money away this is the nature of
politics politics is compromised and it
has been since day one men have been
trading things to influence and power
and and you do you compromise with your
enemy your enemy's enemy becomes your
friend and all of that and it's very
very complicated it's not black and
white and we're not all gonna stay on
our borders and be isolationists and say
we're not playing with anybody so you
know unfortunately we have to go out in
the world and play and make these
compromises and it's
horrific and it's not fair and their
whoever said life was going to be fair
on this planet that's the other thing
but do you think about our democracy
here in America you know when it started
only white male landowners were citizens
and could vote so we have made progress
it's not perfect but we have stuck with
a system but it takes a lot of
commitment to try the system called
democracy and Egypt tried for a year I
mean come on it's gonna take a long time
yeah and can I just say it's a pleasure
to have two women and I who we you know
you guys are allowed to think and do all
that stuff and with your boobs and all
that good stuff